♪ ♪ ♪
- Par un matin de décembre,
les participants arrivent aux
HEC pour leur tout premier cours
à l'École des dirigeants des
Premières nations.
- Kwé kwé
- Ils sont 17 : des élus et des
administrateurs d'organisations
autochtones provenant des quatre
coins du Québec.
Parmi eux,nenenene
Bacon-Charland, la vice-cheffe
du Conseil des Innus de
Pessamit, sur la Côte-Nord.
SUZANNE BACON-CHARLAND, vice-
cheffe Conseil Innus Pessamit,
- Moi, je suis très fébrile,
je suis enthousiaste. Très tôt
le matin comme ça, c'est rare
mais... moi, je suis prête,
je suis prête. Moi, j'adore
le logo qui est un canot, moi
je m'embarque dans quelque
chose.anananant l'École des
dirigeants, on va pouvoir
connaître des gens, on va
pouvoir poser nos questions,
on va s'outiller.
- Et il y a aussi Adam Jourdain,
un Innu qui est directeur
général adjoint du Conseil des
Atikamekws de Wemotaci, en Haute
Mauricie.
Déjà détenteur d'un
baccalauréat en administration
des affaires, il gère plusieurs
ésésésésés en commandites.
ADAM JOURDAIN, dg adjoint
Conseil Atikamekw de Wemotaci
- Plusieurs sphères en
foren n n n n a un comptoir
alimentaire aussi, on a
une station service, on a
une pourvoirie, fait qu'on en a
s s s s s dont une sicerie aussi
qui s'en vient. Fait que,
on commence à s'expansionner au
niveau économique
- Il espère que la formation lui
permettra de devenir un meilleur
gestionnaire pourerererere
bénéficier sa communauté....
- Ça nous permet de nous
rassembler puis de voir des
problématiques, puis de voir
peut-être des solutions qu'on
n'aurait pas vu si on avait été
tout seul.
- Bienvenue, welco
Je suis contente de vous voir
tout le monde ici.
- L'École des dirigeants des
Premières nations est une idée
de Manon Jeanotte, une Micmac,
et de Ken Rock, un Innu;dededed.
Ils ont tous deux fait le même
constat : les formations
universitaires sont rarement
adaptées à la
autochtone.
MANON JEANNOTTE, dir. École
dirigeants Premières Nations
- Tout ce qui a rapport aux
Premières nations, c'est quand
même malheureusement la Loi sur
les indiens et c'est pas
les mêmes structures, c'est pas
les mêmes lois, c'est très très
différent. Il faut toujours
savoir comment on va appliquer
ça chez nous tandis que là,
tandis quefafafafafafafait,
on l'a co-créé et c'est vraiment
à partir de comment ça se passe
chez nous.
- Ken Rock et elle sont donc
allés cogner à la porte des HEC,
qui a déjà une École des
dirigeants depuis plus de
65 ans. L'établissement a tout
de suite accepté d'épauler
ses deux anciens étudiants pour
créer une école dédiée aux
autochtones.
SERGE LAFRANCE, directeur, École
des dirigeants HEC Montréal
- On est là pour donner des
ress l l l l l l l l'envol. Et
dans ce cadre-là, le souhait,
l'ambition dans quelques années,
c'est peut-être construire un
Première nations Inc. Mais
l'image, à l'image, et selon les
valeurs des Premières nations.
- Au bout de quatre modules de
trois jours en présentiel et en
virtuel, les participants
pourront obtenir une
certification.
Tous les cours sont donnés en
t,t,t,t,t,t,t,t, par
un formateur autochtone et
un enseignant des HEC.
- C'est l'équilibre entre
la vision qu'on a du monde
la vision traditionnelle puis
là, le deuxième oeil va être
la vision académique HEC.
- Si près, mais si loin des
fois, mais on travaille
ensemble.
- Le premier module porte surhi.
On traite notamment de
l'intelligence émotionnelle.
Un des formateurs invités pour
l'occasion est nul a
Ghislain Picard, le chef de
l'Assemblée des Premières
nations. On nous demande alors
de quitter la salle, pour
favoriser un partage sans
retenue.
- On a été plus, je pourrais
dire dans l'émotion, puis dansçs
aussi en tant que communautés,
nos aspirations, nos rêves.
J'ai trouvé ça vraiment
intéressant.
- Je pense qu'on est tous animés
par ces mêmes sentiments-là, de
vouloir aider notre population à
grandir, à s'épanouir.
GHISLAIN PICARD, chef, Assemblé.
- Ce que j'ai vu ce matin, des
personnes qui se sentent bien
dans les responsabilités
qu'ils ont ou qu'e
assumer, et qui ont l'impression
qu'ils peuvent contribuer
davantage. Pour moi, la démarche
c'est aussi pour aller chercher,
aller instaurer, instaurer
cette confiance-là, l'estime,
la dignité et plein de valeurs
qui ont été écorchées depuis151.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Fin mars, c'est dans
la communauté huronne-wendat de
Wendake qu'est donné
le quatrième et dernier module
du programme.
- ititititititititititite à
aller sur Slido pour mettre
un mot qui, selon vous, définit
c'est quoi une bonne
gouvernance.
- Le cours auquel nous assistons
porte sur la gouvernance.
Les participants échangent avec
le groupe et les formateurs.
- Souvent, les théories
éducatives, qu'on reçoit à
l'université, puis tu arrives en
communauté, c'est vraiment
MARJOLAINE SIOUÏ, vice-présiden.
Fondation Nouveaux Sentiers
- Et je rêve du jour où on va
pouvoir affirmer ce
toujours pouvoir créer
nos propres structures qui vont
davantage coller à la réalité.
- Alors que l'aventure tire à
sa fin, Adam estime que
l'expérience a été bénéfique.
Il a notamment apprécié
le co-enseignement.
- De combiner ces professe
avec des gens qui connaissent
la réalité, tu sais, on voit des
choses, des situations vraiment
commune aux communautés,
fait que je pense que la formule
est excellente.
- On a eu de grosses réflexions,
on essaie de ramener ça dans noe
c'est ça qui est fantastique.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Début mai, de retour aux HEC
poe e e e e e e e e e e e e des
certifications.
(applaudissements)
Pour Suzanne et Adam, c'est v vs
récompensés.
- C'est immense la fierté que
j'ai envers tout le programme e,
moi, en tant que personne,
individuellement, mais je suis
fière de tout le monde.
- Et la eseseseseseseseseseseses
résultats tangibles.
- J'ai déjà apporté certains
changements. On parle
d'un comité d'innovation à
Wemotaci, on parle également
d'une nouvelle façon de procéder
dans les conseils
d'administration.
- L'École des dirigeants des
Premières nations a de grandes
ambitions.
Des prog
gestionnaires et les
entrepreneurs seront lancés au
cours des prochains mois.
On a pour objectif de former
1000 étudiants au cours des
cinq prochaines années.
(chant autochtone)